die FDP auf Konfrontationskurs das
umstrittene Gebäude Energiegesetz
blockieren die Liberalen derzeit Robert
Habeck fordern sie mit 113 Fragen heraus
dieser sein Wirtschaftsministerium erst
einmal beantworten bevor das Gesetz im
Bundestag beraten werden kann die Grünen
wiederum drohen andere Gesetze die der
FDP wichtig sind liegen zu lassen der
Streit droht zu eskalieren doch nun
scheint es doch Annäherung zu geben
überraschen kündigt habeg Ende letzter
Woche an das Gesetz zu entschärfen
ich will das Gesetz besser machen mir
ist wichtig dass der Umstieg auf
erneuerbares heizen pragmatisch
funktioniert für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger einfach machbar ist und sozial
flankiert wird
konkret will Habeck Besitzern von
Bestandsgebäuden nun doch länger Zeit
geben sie dürfen auch über das nächste
Jahr hinaus Heizungen einbauen die mit
fossilen Brennstoffen Wärme erzeugen wie
lange sagt habe ich nicht die Pflicht
sorgt klimafreundlichen Heizung soll nur
noch für Neubauten gelten die ab Januar
2024 genehmigt werden
weitreichende Zugeständnisse nun sei die
FDP am Zug so die Grünen die das Gesetz
noch vor der Sommerpause verabschieden
wollen wo gibt es Möglichkeiten sich
gemeinsam zu verständigen auf
Verbesserungen des Gesetzes und dazu hat
Robert Habeck unter anderem pragmatische
Vorschläge gemacht ich erwarte jetzt von
allen Koalitionspartnern in der Ampel
dass sie hier jetzt konstruktiv in die
Gespräche gehen und vor allen Dingen
dass sie das ordentliche
parlamentarische Verfahren auch
ermöglichen bisher steht die FDP dort ja
weiterhin auf der Bremse leider
Wirtschaftsverbände begrüßen hadex
Zugeständnisse der eigentümerverband
Haus und Grund warnt es dürfe aber nicht
bei kosmetischen änderungen bleiben auch
die FDP kommt mit neuen Vorschlägen sie
will den Emissionshandel für Gebäude und
Verkehr auf 2024 vorziehen Preise für
fossile Brennstoffe wie Öl und Gas
würden dann früher steigen das soll den
Umstieg auf klimafreundliche Heizungen
befördern heute wollen sich Abgeordnete
der Ampelkoalition auf Einladung von
Robert Habeck im Wirtschaftsministerium
treffen es gilt einen Kompromiss zu
finden
sprechen wir darüber jetzt mit dem
spd-generalsekretär Kevin Kühnert bei
uns im Studio schönen guten Morgen
herzlich willkommen guten Morgen Herr
Kühnert eigentlich hat man sich ja Ende
März beim Koalitionsausschuss der
wirklich viele viele Stunden gedauert
hat auf alles geeinigt was ist
eigentlich schief gelaufen dass man
jetzt zwei Monate später noch mal
darüber reden muss und bis jetzt immer
noch streitet ja das sind jetzt nicht
nur rumreiche letzte Woche gewesen das
haben glaube ich auch alle so weit
zugestanden es ist eines der größten
Reformvorhaben der Koalition in dieser
Wahlperiode insofern ist da auch
genügend Substanz um sich
auseinanderzusetzen als leere sollten
wir mitnehmen wenn das in ein paar
Wochen gesetzgeberisch durch ist als
Lehrer sollten wir mitnehmen dass man
die Zeit und Aufmerksamkeit die man als
Koalition hat zum überzeugen zum werben
und zum Einbringen ernsthafter
Verbesserungsvorschläge nutzen sollte
und nicht dafür koalitionsverhandlung
zwei Jahre später noch mal zu
wiederholen okay sie gehen also davon
aus dass das ein paar Wochen durch ist
dazu kommen wir gleich noch mal aber
trotzdem möchte ich noch mal nachfragen
denn man hat ja nicht nur im
koalitionsausschluss schon lange
gesprochen das ganze war auch schon im
Kabinett und man hat sich ja tatsächlich
schwarz auf weiß geeinigt unter anderem
auf den Zeitplan dass das vor der
Sommerpause durchkommt jetzt sagt die es
die FDP Entschuldigung der Zeitplan sei
nachrangig können Sie in diesem Punkt
Robert habe ich verstehen dass er von
Wort braucht
wäre jetzt nicht meine Wortwahl aber
natürlich ist der Zeitplan überhaupt
nicht nachrangig denn wir sprechen ja
über ein Gesetzentwurf der eine Pflicht
zumindest für einzelne Gebäude ab 1.1.24
enthalten soll und wir alle haben nun
ausreichend mitgekriegt da draußen
sitzen viele hunderttausend oder gar
Millionen Menschen die sich Fragen
betrifft mich das hat ab nächsten Jahr
oder nicht soll ich was machen oder
nicht und deswegen ist ein Zeitplan ganz
wichtig weil er entscheidet darüber wie
lange die umstellungsfrist noch ist
entscheidet darüber ab wann die
Heizungsinstallateure in Deutschland den
Kunden und Kunden sagen können ab 1
sieht folgendermaßen aus und wir haben
ja noch einen zweiten zeitlich
limitierenden Faktoren nämlich das
Klimaschutzgesetz in Deutschland wir
haben per Gesetz uns vorgenommen bis
2045 Klima neutral sein zu wollen ohne
unseren heizungssektor geht das nicht
und deswegen ist jedes Jahr später dass
wir mit dem heizungsaustausch anfangen
eines weniger was uns für die Umstellung
des regenerativen heizen zur Verfügung
steht nach Besserung angekündigt
auch bei zum Beispiel Härtefällen und
bei der Förderung was ihrer Partei auch
sehr wichtig ist wie optimistisch sind
sie dass es heute endlich den Kompromiss
gibt ob es jetzt heute ist oder morgen
oder in dieser Woche ist glaube ich
nicht ganz so entscheidend
wichtig ist dass wir vor der
parlamentarischen Sommerpause durch das
parlamentarische Verfahren durch sind
das geht durchaus noch die letzte
Sitzungswoche wäre gut gewesen um schon
zu starten mit der ersten Lesung im
Deutschen Bundestag das hat die FDP noch
nicht ermöglichen können in der nächsten
Sitzungswoche muss es gelingen und
deswegen muss jetzt diese Woche der
Knoten durchschlagen werden heute sind
dafür wichtige Gespräche und ich würde
sagen schon in den letzten Tagen hat man
gemerkt die Rhetorik hat sich bei vielen
deutlich verändert von der
verweigerungskommunikation ist es zur
ermöglichungskommunikation übergegangen
und das ist ein wichtiger Hinweis darauf
dass einige jetzt nicht mehr damit
rechnen das Gesetz verhindern zu können
und das ist auch richtig so die SPD
scheint von den drei ampelparteien am
wenigsten unter diesem Streit zu leiden
wir haben ein paar Zahlen ZDF
Politbarometer dazu und zwar eben nur
drei Prozent der SPD die Schuld daran
während Regierungsvorhaben nur schwer
Vorankommen 18 Prozent den Grünen und 34
Prozent der FDP kommt ihnen kommt der
SPD der Streit zwischen grün und FDP
vielleicht sogar ganz gelegen
ausdrücklich nicht das ist unsere
gemeinsame Regierung die SPD führt diese
Regierung und wir wollen das am Ende der
Wahlperiode eine Mehrheit der Menschen
in Deutschland sagt in Anbetracht der
großen Krisen sind das gute Jahre in
Deutschland gewesen das wird nicht
funktionieren wenn nur einem
Koalitionspartner eine anständige Bilanz
zugeschrieben wird wir müssen zusammen
erfolgreich sein wenn sie sagen die SPD
regiert diese Koalition ehrlich gesagt
in letzter Zeit war schon auffällig dass
ich Kanzler stolz ziemlich zurückhält
haben Sie da nicht manchmal auch im
Machtwort vermisst bleiben wir bei dem
heizungsgesetz als Beispiel da bin ich
die letzten Wochen oft gefragt worden ob
wir denn gar keine Meinung dazu hätten
wir haben genau die Meinung dazu gefragt
genau aber zum Beispiel in der in dem
Streit um die akw-laufzeit hat er
irgendwann macht dort gesprochen von
seiner Richtlinienkompetenz gebraucht
gemacht und hat nicht gemacht dass er
das nicht mit Freude tut weil es ist
immer nur die zweitbeste Lösungen mit
einem Machtwort eine Debatte beenden zu
müssen und der hat deutlich gemacht er
wäre dazu bereit auch einen Knoten zu
durchschlagen in der Frage des
heizungsgesetzes aber der Zeitpunkt war
eben noch nicht so weit dass das
notwendig waren es ist immer besser wenn
im parlamentarischen Verfahren gemeinsam
ein Weg gefunden wird das ist
pseudostärke wenn ein Regierungschef nur
um zu zeigen was er für ein toller
Hengst ist die ganze Zeit auf dem Tisch
hauen muss gute moderne Führung besteht
eben nicht da drin der lauteste Maxe zu
sein da müssen Großbritannien in den
letzten Jahren gesehen Boris Johnson hat
genauso regiert immer schön auf den
Tisch klein genutzt hat es ihm und
seinem Land am Ende sicherlich nicht gut
also sind wir gespannt was heute bei dem
Treffen dabei herauskommt oder
spätestens im Laufe dieser Woche sie
gehen davon aus diese Woche wird es ein
Kompromiss geben Kevin kühn und der SPD
Generalsekretär war das vielen Dank für
ihre Einordnung vielen Dank für das
Gespräch